congratulations buddy uh it is so
wonderful to see you there
holding that that momentous moment right
now um
what does it mean to be able to win with
the song worldwide
beautiful like what does that song
represent to you
um that song means the world to me
because especially for 2020 with all the
hatred that's been put in the world by
the media
um no offense to you guys i'm not saying
you are doing it but um
i'm just saying there's a there's been a
bunch of dismiss misled
information um and this song to me
just shows where the world's leading uh
where it's in the future of our
children's hands
that's why i put my daughter uh in the
music video
and so i'm just so excited that this
this song meant so much to people and
country music
and and helped the world out the doors
are opening for everybody
uh and country music is embracing you
know everybody
females men black men anybody
so it just means the world to me and
also celebration
um we threw a party uh back in my
manager's office
and we left them to come here and so
we're gonna go back and hang out with
everybody it's just a bunch of important
people
um in nashville that we get to go back
and see
so we're just all so excited